hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Taylor
Bradley we're gonna check out this viral
video
Arnold acts out his films in six minutes
I hear this is the real Arnold
Schwarzenegger parrying himself I'm
really excited I already [ __ ] up I
love Arnold like I I love Arnold movies
I think they're a blast they are they've
always been they've always been super
fun I don't think I've ever seen him in
anything that I was just like oh my god
that was horrible
yeah you know like there's this new
movie coming out on Friday that stars
Arnold but I hear it's like a really
good dramatic performance for me really
which is really interesting actually
because I don't know a lot about what's
going on with movies right now but I
care more about watching cheesy bad
acting Arnold oh yeah great I can't wait
more yeah okay
what's the late this evening roll call
will be a celebration of the film career
of the one the only mr. Arnold
Schwarzenegger oh cool so cool how he
played
[Applause]
well then Lou Brady King certainly look
ready this is all right let's go
okay donan what is best in life to crush
your enemies see them driven before you
and have a lamentation of their weapon
[Music]
yeah I love this luck
[Applause]
milk is for babies when you get older
you drink beer
[Applause]
are we doing a Expendables number one
two or three but what's the difference I
don't know I never saw any of them are
you scared why you should be because
this green bill is gonna kick your big
ass ha ha well I Green Berets for
breakfast and right now I'm very very
hungry yeah ohyes all suited up I'll be
back
[Applause]
this one is I love seated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you do me a favor sure that's a
vapor or sometimes favors hook get your
Octomom I don't sound like that
I vote sound like that I think it sounds
like there they go let's go to the next
movie the next movie okay I hope you
leave enough room for my fist because
I'm gonna write it in your stomach and
break it then spine
[Applause]
you've done a lot of film oh yeah yes
I'm Batman everybody freeze
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my nipples are so sensitive
[Applause]
Oh Oh God
[Applause]
dance for me no no slower and more sexy
[Music]
that is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
- right
[Music]
I can't get up I've election quiet quiet
everybody you give me a headache maybe
it's a tumor those other tumor it's not
a too late all please oh say you want to
be a farmer here's a couple of acres
[Applause]
he'll just give you this mom cook it
down cookie down
[Applause]
hasta la vista baby
[Applause]
[Music]
that's pretty great I'll never forget
that
pretty great thankful oh my goodness I
grew up on most of those films yeah
I've seen most of those films multiple
times predator commando Terry and Tamara
one Terminator 2 integrated high regard
called True Lies jingle although like
it's crazy how he hasn't been able to
research his career like to the big box
office star level again like this movies
I've just been doing okay
I hope Terminator 5 does well you know I
mean it comes out in like a month or two
it's like watching this was so much
nostalgia like it was very heartwarming
yeah cuz it's like I remember all the
twins like he had such a good time with
it you could tell they were just goofing
around and he was just he just looks so
thrilled yeah it was it was nice to see
him just really embrace the fun of this
and the cheesiness and be willing to
parody himself and instead of him making
it like you know because some actors are
like I would never parody my old work
because that's what its best but he's
like willing to totally make fun of it
and even repeat some of the catchphrases
like that get to the chopper I know were
great those and I feel like Keith's had
to say there was so many times now to
like all of his fans yeah see the wise
Bay the line and he just totally still
gets a kick out of it oh yeah totally it
makes me want to see him in more movies
again yes because when you know when
times you see his arms he's still like
oh my god
small person yeah if choices like yeah
you forget how Buffy was I don't know
like if these are literally centuries
yeah he might be in a sixties now that's
incredible yeah still looks great
yeah like seriously like I I forgot just
how buff he was yes yes you know like I
got used to seeing him a suit everywhere
he went so yeah that's it's pretty
[ __ ] cool to see him back in action
like this thank you so much for saying
that was out that was a blast really
really love that
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Taylor has
a channel that you just read launched
you should check it out it's a total
blast and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
trying to get product placement by
getting a certain amount of followers
wallets yep
it's great to hold your money condoms
cards cards ecstasy um if you don't have
a place to hide room cocaine you just
shove it in there fortune cookie
fortunes that you like to say mm-hmm
that are inspiring um nostril hair
um pennies that you're never gonna
actually spend mm-hmm um and uh I
actually carry my left testicle around
me everywhere I go it's disgusting no
animal oh no because you're gonna pull
out something weird I don't trust your
wallet I don't trust it no girl ever
wants us to my won't Christian Hernandez
hey it'd be really cool if I got a shout
out I'm a high school senior looking to
go to the Air Force and after pursuing a
career in art your videos are the most
hilarious and you're my favorite reactor
on YouTube okay well thank you Christian
Hernandez going to the Air Force huh and
pursue your career in art do it it's
totally worth it it's totally worth it
um just so you know Air Force career and
art career um
they say that's one of the best ways to
get a really high income and a really
hot girl I feel like girls love me okay
why no I'm sarcastic I'd yes girl yes
sarcastically you'll make a lot of money
non sarcastically yes you will you will
get plenty of [ __ ] my friend right now
you better start telling ladies you're
going to the Air Force you should even
like kind of get your hair cut like an
air force officer really look like
you're serious about it oh yeah chicks
will dig that dude chicks will dig that
in before you know what you're having an
orgy with like ten women and you're the
only guy and then it's it's all anal and
and then you know they're like ten
chicks blow once which is so like
impossible to do like don't ever list
the porn videos when they say like 10
chicks 1 you just can't get 10 people to
fit around one dick so deal where that
Christian oh you need to wear a - accent
and then done mm-hmm you need a dictator
dick sucker if you're in the Air Force